that's it has been thought mercedes-benz
has been enjoying great sales figures
recently explains our car man tyne hood
and confidence leads to daring something
new car makers like looking at what
their neighbors are up to some time ago
mercedes-benz brought out the CLS
four-door coupe a and suddenly there was
a corresponding model from BMW this time
it was BMW that first launched the x6
sonam mercedes have an SUV kupe to a new
edition of a ji le let's see what is God
listen the sneezes fog socon we tested
the souped-up AMG version which delivers
270 kilowatts of output and 520 newton
meters of torque the three-point old
liter twin-turbo v6 engine drives the
2.2 tunner to 100 km/h in 5.7 seconds
official fuel consumption is 8.9 liters
for 100 kilometers with co2 emissions at
209 g/km
baba developed I know praises the
workmanship and there are now five
suspension modes ranging from dynamic
sport plus too slippery for poor
conditions he also loves the stylish
presentation of engine data in the
central display more to a Dalton and
Mittal display the 9-speed automatic
transmission in the GLA translates into
maximum power delivery on the practical
side you can use paddles instead of the
accelerator to shift down from ninth to
fifth when you need to overtake quickly
the new GLA has indisputable SUV
credentials that set it apart from most
other coupe a's among the design
highlights black wing mirrors and window
surrounds the AMG front apron and the
21-inch AMG alloy wheels and that AMG
badge means this beefcake can really let
rip and roar and let's not forget that
AMG rear apron what started as an
m-class now has the g-class designation
with the last initial a hint at the
e-class segment there's ample cargo
capacity between 650 and 1720 leaders
but it's high rear sill does get in the
way
the interior of the 450 AMG is plush
indeed as befits the target clientele
the central monitor sits atop the
dashboard the sports steering wheel is
clad in napa leather with aluminum trim
and the AMG edition has sport seats up
front
that's messiness Penske Lionel sees the
mercedes-benz GLA kupe as a more
handsome x6 although it shares similar
problems to the BMW the GLA is very big
and heavy weighing around 2.2 tons which
is not good for fuel economy rear
visibility is poor the trunk is big
enough but the big downer is the waist
high loading sill so hauling in a crate
of drinks takes a lot of muscles
the gioi 450 AMG is certainly a nice
looking option if you're into this kind
of car you can cruise and style with
this baby and the performance is awesome
it's not all good news however this
heavy powerful car is likely to be
thirsty too and the co2 emissions will
not please the environmentally aware and
the big points loss comes from the high
loading sill
you